[Music]
[Applause]
Steve Phillips former Mets GM I was
listening to Steve earlier this morning
on Mad Dog radio and he was bringing up
some interesting things about show he
utani and uh he hosts the leadoff spot
every morning from 7:00 to 10: on
siriusxm's MLB Network radio channel
Steve good to see you again give us Dan
give us sort of the sense of why Toronto
is kind of emerging as a I don't know if
a favorite but certainly a dark horse
here for show he Otani yeah I think it's
really down to the Dodgers and the Blue
Jays right now and you know I think that
the thing about the Blue Jays you know
you think about when Otani came over you
know he didn't choose the brand you know
he didn't go Yankees Pinstripes he
didn't go dodger blue he went to Anaheim
like it just it surprised all of us a
little bit but I think that within that
there's a statement that he isn't about
everybody else's brand and what he he's
done since then is he's built his own
brand to such an extreme level as of an
international star you know and it's
funny because I think about how many
times we said boy if Mike Trout played
on the East Coast what he'd be such a
bigger star well oton didn't play on the
east coast and he's the biggest star we
have in baseball I think it it really is
about the player and so so you you think
about Otani making this decision and I
look at the idea of if he go if he goes
to the Dodgers he's sharing the brand
platform right it's there's some part of
him that there's only so much room for
brand power and he's going to share it
with the Dodger name if he goes to
Toronto he owns it and he owns Canada he
owns the United States and he owns Japan
and he becomes an international star now
you know he he wants to win Toronto will
give them that opportunity from
everything I've sourced out there they
could afford Bo bashet Vladimir gero Jr
and Otani moving forward they've got a
really good pitching staff right now
their window to win here is in the short
term but I think the other thing to keep
in mind is you know every team that gets
him thinks well we're going to Market
him in a way that we're going to pay for
his salary now I've never seen those
numbers really work but you can Market
them with broadcasting rights and
sponsorship ads and you know you'll put
patches on the shirt now that could be
worth millions of dollars but but the
other part of it for them is they're you
know Rogers Corporation owns the team in
Toronto sportset the TV network they're
a Communications company with cell
phones and all of that they want to
expand in Asia and they're the one team
in the hunt for Otani where their Core
Business of the ownership will benefit
financially with revenue and income if
they sign Otani so it's not just the
baseball revenues it's the core business
and that is where I think they could
become the team that could easily spend
the most money to try to lure him to
come to their Club how much does the
ballpark matter for
Otani well you know geography doesn't
matter I think you know we've heard the
ballpark could now the reality is that's
a good thing for Toronto he likes
contained environments his numbers where
he's he's uh uh you know performed the
best are in domes and in the better
weather and so he crushed the Blue Jays
this year when he went to the Rogers
Center put up big numbers there homered
in multiple games uh and so honestly
that actually benefits a bit but La
certainly will you know the argument for
the Dodgers his Medical Teams out there
that worked on his elbow uh he's
comfortable there uh you know he knows
the community he wouldn't have to move
he's buying a house out there but this
he's going to make enough money you can
buy houses in in every Major League City
if he wants to so uh but I do think that
it's down to the Blue Jays and and I
would not have thought that it's a it's
a different move but this is an
ownership driven decision by Toronto in
retrospect should the angels have tried
harder to trade Otani oh absolutely it
was honestly it was baseball malpractice
that they didn't I mean it made no sense
they they decided to keep him and and
then they said okay and while we're
doing it let's go out there in a double
header and run him into the ground you
know so he pitches the the the one
hitter and then he plays in the second
game hits two homers leaves with cramps
and it was at that point that his body
was rejecting like a like a an organ
rejecting being a two-way player cramped
up from that point forward elbow breaks
down uh and so yeah they should have
moved him it would have been the right
thing instead they kept them traded away
a bunch of prospects that even if they
signed them those are players they would
have to have play with them to be able
to afford the contract he's going to get
and so it was just it was an owner doing
a money grab and it's an owner who's not
going to be in it for the long haul he
had it on the market to sell and then he
pulled it off and so don't be surprised
if you see R Mareno put the team up for
sale here within the next two years
what's the uh downside to signing Otani
so here's the thing I wouldn't sign him
I wouldn't sign him I I look he's great
but uh I think the risk is so
significant in him being a two-way
player as I said I think his body
started rejecting the notion of being a
two-way player and and think about this
he just had a second elbow procedure I
don't know if it was Tommy John or not
but he's the most protected starting
pitcher in baseball uh you know pitches
once every once a week once every six
days and his elbow still broke down and
so what that tells us and for the second
time so what it tells us is that that
even being that as protected as he was
he broke down so how much more can I
protect him and how do you manage a
pitching staff uh while you've got to
keep everybody else on six days or seven
days too and and I said to Toronto's
general manager Ros hackins I said have
you checked with your pitchers how
they're going to like it a year from now
if they all have to go to a six-man
rotation because don't you think that
matters and he goes yeah well it
certainly doesn't matter we'll have to
manage it and there's nuances around it
and everything else I think they want
the player and they're going to try to
Fig figure it out later great stuff
thank you for your insights and uh good
to have you back on yeah nice to talk to
you to Dan that's Steve Phillips former
Mets GM you can hear him on the leadoff
spot every morning 7: to 10:00 a.m.
eastern on SiriusXM MLB Network radio
show